en général c'est la première fois que
vous acceptez de répondre sur l'écran de
la télévision aux questions d'un
journaliste
je voudrais donc essayer ce soir de vous
poser les principales questions que la
plupart des français ceux qui
s'apprêtent à voter pour vous comme ceux
qui s'apprêtent à ne pas voter pour vous
j'aimerais vous poser s'il était à ma
place ce soir et je dirais même et
brèves ou posés depuis bien avant depuis
bien longtemps et bien avant que la
campagne électorale pour la désignation
du président de la république ne soit
engagée la première de ces questions
sera si vous le voulez bien celle-ci
vous avez écrit en tête du premier tome
de aux mémoires de guerre
toute ma vie je me suis fait une
certaine idée de la france et nous
savons que cette certaine idée de la
france est élevée et qu'elle est
exigeante seulement vous voyez mon
général les français ont souvent
l'impression que vous vous faites
également deux une certaine idée est que
cette certaine idée vous faites des
français est très différente de celle
que vous faites de la france en d'autres
termes qu'elle est beaucoup moins élevé
et je crois que les français ça ne leur
fait pas très plaisir
cher monsieur il est vrai que c'est la
première fois depuis longtemps que j'ai
le plaisir de m'entretenir avec un
journaliste en particulier si j'ose
m'exprimer ainsi car il ya beaucoup de
gens qui nous voient qu'ils nous
entendent très souvent j'ai une chambre
à des journalistes par centaines mais
enfin il est vrai que cette fois ci en
voilà un
vous me parlez de l'idée que je me fais
de la france ce n'est pas un sujet
nouveau
il est tout à fait vrai je dirais que
c'est ma raison d'être
il est tout à fait vrai que depuis
toujours et aujourd'hui je me fais un
effet de la france une certaine idée je
veux dire par là qu'à mon sens elle est
quelque chose de très grand de très
particulier
c'est du reste je le pense ressentie par
le monde entier
il y a même là quelque chose
extraordinaire
nerfs dans nos malheurs on s'en aperçoit
tout de suite
et quand nous sommes heureux prospère
lorieux efforts on s'en aperçoit aussi
dans la mesure où les gens nous
regardent avec envie
c'est vrai la france est une chose
à meyzieu très considérable très valable
et elle doit avoir dans le monde quels
qu'ils soient toutes époques
naturellement d'après les circonstances
elle doit avoir un rôle à elle il faut
que la france joue son rôle
c'est exact et pour qu'elle joue son
rôle il faut qu'elle soit la france les
français les français ceux qui font la
france c'est lui qui en sont
responsables
le génération en génération la france
est plus que les français du moment
la france vient de loin elle est ce
qu'elle est maintenant
et puis à l'avenir autrement dit la
france
embrasse toutes les générations de
français est d'abord bien entendu les
générations vivantes ces générations
vivantes sont responsables de la france
et c'est ainsi c'est vrai que je
considère dans leur ensemble les
français et c'est ainsi que je souhaite
que les français dans leur ensemble se
considèrent eux-mêmes
il y a à cet égard là entre eux et pour
cela une solidarité que je dis être
national et faute de laquelle la france
risque de n'être pas ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle est de tout temps et par
conséquent de ne plus jouer son rôle est
de ne plus à proprement parler exister
voilà ce que je peux vous dire des
français par rapport à la france
deux autres français d'aujourd'hui par
rapport à la france de toujours en
général puisque nous parlons des
français je voudrais également vous dire
ceci
les français ont souvent l'impression
que par nature profonde peut-être vous
êtes davantage préoccupé de la conduite
des affaires de la france à niveau très
élevé que de leurs propres problèmes à
eux leurs problèmes quotidiens à leurs
problèmes matériels on a exprimé cela
d'une façon schématique un peu militaire
en disant que vous ne vous intéressiez
pas beaucoup pas l'intendance
or les français s'ils se sentent
concernés évidemment par les affaires de
la france se sentent également aussi
très concerné par ce que j'appellerais
familièrement les affaires de leur porte
monnaie
ce qu'il y a dans leur porte-monnaie ce
que ce qu'il ya dans leur porte-monnaie
leur permet de se procurer et je me
permets de vous le dire très
respectueusement mais très franchement
les français ont souvent l'impression
que vous êtes un peu au dessus de ces
contingences
on m'a prêté en effet ce mot que je n'ai
jamais dit et à plus forte raison que
j'ai jamais pensé l'intendance suit ça
ce sont les blacks pour les journaux je
n'ai pas besoin de vous dire ce que
j'entends parle en réalité je vous le
répète les français sont responsables de
la france mais ils sont sur la terre ils
ont leur vie et pour que la france
existe il faut que les français existent
pour que la france soit forte il faut
que les français soient pour asper
autant que possible bien entendu et cela
je sais je ne dirais pas mieux personne
vais certainement autant que personne
alors voici la question et notamment la
question du jour la question plus
exactement de notre époque qui est une
époque économique et social il y en a
ce sont les démagogues penchant le mot
il faut bien le dire ce sont les partis
c'est à dire ceux qui caressent les
clientèles pour être élu et souvent les
journaux qui caressent les clientèles
vont être lus alors cela assez
volontiers et même très volontiers 10
mais il en faut plus pour intel il en
faut plus pour intel il faut faire
davantage pour les ouvriers il faut
faire plus pour les paysans il faut
faire mieux pour les cadres il faut
arroser davantage les fonctionnaires les
agents des services publics
il faut même donné un petit peu plus aux
chefs d'entreprises avec un peu
l'inflation
il faut beaucoup plus logement ils font
beaucoup plus d'autoroutes
il faut beaucoup plus de téléphone il
faut un enseignement encore bien mieux
organisé avec beaucoup plus d'école à
tous les étages et d'universités et
cetera et cetera
j'achèterai common c'est vulgairement
com
oui mais c'est aussi ce que les français
individuellement se disent si vous
voulez dire que je ne suis pas sur ce
plan là vous avez raison moi je suis sur
le plan que voici
il faut que le peuple français soit
prospère il le faut parce que s'il n'est
pas prospère la france dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure ne pourrait pas
jouer son rôle dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui
donc rien ne m'occupe davantage depuis
bien longtemps que la prospérité
nationale
je dirais même puisque je vais parler
d'un tendance que ça me fait un peu
sourire car si vous y faites attention
rien rien rien de ce qui a été fait
d'important au point de vue économique
et social depuis la libération n'a été
fait excepté par mon
gouvernement après la libération
c'était le point de vue social immédiate
qui l'emportait il fallait que nous
retrouvions après ces deux secousses
épouvantable il fallait que nous
trouvions notre équilibre
alors mon gouvernement a fait les
assurances sociales les allocations
familiales les nationalisations les
comités d'entreprise et ses terrains
aujourd'hui ou plus exactement depuis
que je suis revenue depuis sept ans
c'est l'économique qui me paraît
l'emporté sur tout le reste parce
qu'elle est la condition de tous et en
particulier la condition du progrès
social
c'est pas la peine de nous raconter des
histoires si nous sommes pauvres ou en
désordres économiquement parlant
nous ne progresserons pas socialement au
contraire si nous sommes prospère et à
condition d'avoir du que l'état fasse
son devoir
tous les français en profite et en
profiteront alors justement général est
ce que nous pourrions essayer un peu de
passer en revue ses différents ces
différents domaines je me nomme les
français quelquefois pense que les
choses comme vous dites ne vont pas
aussi bien qu'elle devrait aller d'abord
le niveau des prix le niveau de vie des
français
niveau de vie des français pas plus tard
que samedi j'ai des chiffres
à mon avis ils sont éclatants depuis
sept ans je répète que le niveau de vie
des français a augmenté de 3,7 pour cent
pas et que d'après ce qui est décidé par
notre cinquième plan et ce qui est
devenu possible grâce à nos progrès
économique le niveau de vie des français
est monté à 4 % par an ça veut dire que
18 ans après mon retour 18 ans après mon
retour
le niveau de vie des français sera
doublé ce n'est pas si mal alors c'est
comme le bonheur ça existe par
comparaison par contre pas raison avant
mon retour je demande que l'on considère
ce qui n était ce qui en était c'était
que les prix montaient depuis 1946
jusqu'en 1958 automatiquement en moyenne
de 10% par an et que tout ce qu'on
faisait pour les salaires pour les
traitements et aussi pour les revenus
paysans et id evra et à mesure par cette
augmentation des prix il est
parfaitement exact que tout en faisant
monter le niveau de vie comme je le dis
le niveau de vie réel et bien il est
parfaitement exact que mon gouvernement
à stabiliser les prix dans toute la
mesure où à notre époque c'est possible
au lieu que les prix augmentent de 10%
par an comme c'était le cas avant 58
il augmente maintenant du deuil ni % par
an il n'y a pas un pays d'europe
occidentale où ce soit aussi certain que
les prix sont limités dans leur
ascension que chez nous il y en a qu'un
ce sont les états unis pourquoi parce
que les états unis grâce à ce qu'on
appelle le golf etc sans le standard
comme vous savez on la facilité
d'exporter leur inflation mais nous
n'avons pas cette facilité il a donc
fallu le faire le plan de stabilisation
je reconnais que ce n'était pas facile
je reconnais qu'il en est résulté des
difficultés par ci par là et notamment
au point de vue de l'expansion immédiate
mais maintenant c'est fait et par
conséquent c'est sur cette base solide
stable avec des budgets en équilibre une
monnaie qui ne bouge pas il est pris je
vous le répète puis pratiquement
n'augmente pour ainsi dire plus et qui
comme vous le savez ne doivent pas
augmenter l'année prochaine plus de 1,5
pour cent par an c'est sur cette base là
que notre niveau de vie s'élève et que
tout le monde y gagne
voilà la réalité pour le niveau
hurle en général tout à l'heure si vous
le voulez bien nous passerons un certain
nombre d'autres questions comme les
routes téléphone
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
l'enseignement sur tout mais vous venez
de parler du niveau de vie de
l'augmentation du niveau de vie de 3 7%
par an mais excusez moi de vous dire
qu'il ya des catégories sociales en
france qui ont l'impression que ces
chiffres parfois ce sont des chiffres
moyens
et puis quel pour elle le niveau de vie
n'augmente pas et je pense en
particulier aux paysans les paysans
trouvent que leur niveau d'il n'augmente
pas ils ont peut être raison et même
sans doute raison il y a
incontestablement un malaise paysan il y
a plus il ya un drame paysan vous le
savez ça manger à qui le dites-vous
mon cher michel droit à qui le
dites-vous
le problème de l'agriculture française
comme était hier le problème de
l'algérie et des colonnes comme est
aujourd'hui encore car ce n'est pas
réglé tout à fait le problème de
l'enseignement
et bien c'est un problème énorme que
nous avons à régler aidant je prétends
que nous le règlement et je mexplique
emblème landes
d'abord problème national au début du
siècle
et bien il y avait les deux tiers des
français qui étaient des ruraux et
aujourd'hui il y en a 20 % évidemment il
y en aura moins dans les années
prochaines
cela résulte de ce qu'on appelle
l'industrialisation
nous étions un pays essentiellement
agricole avec une vie agricole une
agriculture d'ailleurs de subsistance
surtout je veux dire par là que la
plupart de nos paysans vivaient sur la
terre où ils étaient soit qu'il en fût
ce les propriétaires soit qu'ils ont
fusé locataires vivait de ce qu'elle
produisait plus que produisaient leur
exploitation l'ue avait un petit peu de
surplus alors ils le vendaient pour
acheter ce qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
produire eux mêmes ce qui était en
réalité très peu de choses
au point de vue national à cause de
l'industrialisation
problème une monde puisqu'il s'agit d'un
transfert colossal de population de
notre agriculture à notre industrie ce
transfert naturellement on peut ne
trouvait regrettable
on peut en avoir du chagrin ou pensez
bien qu'un homme de mon âge qui très
longtemps dans sa vie a été un soldat
c'est à dire quelqu'un qui savait et qui
sait ce que la france a tiré depuis
toujours et en particulier pour sa
défense de ces paysans il est certain
qu'il ya là une transformation une
évolution qui est à beaucoup d'égards
attristante mais c'est comme ça et le
fait étant ce qu'il est la question est
que la nation s'en accommode et que
cette évolution nationale se fasse dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
voilà au point de vue national comment
se pose le problème paysans transfère
une partie énorme de la population
française de l'agriculture industrie bon
c'est bien que ça peut pas aller sans
secousses sans difficulté sans chagrin
et puis alors il ya un problème propre à
l'agriculture parce que maintenant
l'agriculture est au milieu d'un monde
économique qui pour elle est
complètement nouveau
elle est dans un monde de production de
productivité d'outillage d'un archet
qu'elle ne connaissait pas du tout autre
fois au toit fois je répète c'est
l'agriculture de subsistance
on vivait chacun où on était avec ce
qu'on produisait et puis voilà c'est
plus possible il faut produire ce qu'il
faut produire il faut le produire dans
les meilleures conditions possibles et
il faut par le vent voilà comment se
pose la question à l'agriculture enfin
il ya naturellement une question
infiniment respectable et qui se pose à
chacun de nos agriculteurs
c'est la vie chez
lui car là aussi tout s'est transformé
un paysan comme un ouvrier d'ailleurs
peut plus vivre une veuve juive et a
bien raison comme j'y vais hier il y as
pour un agriculteur une question tôt
chez lui une question d'électricité pour
s'éclairer ou pour avoir la force une
question de chemin pour arriver à sa
ferme
et puis alors il ya une question le
choix de ce qu'il va produire
d'organisation de ces marchés bref et
l'éducation de ses enfants
bref il ya une transformation complète
au point de vue national au point de vue
agricole et au point de vue individuel
pour nos pays''
alors que je fais état à l'heure qu'il
est l'état a pris le problème corps à
corps et il n'avait pas pris corps à
corps avant que je ne revienne sauf
cependant quelque chose de très
important qui avait été fait en 1945 par
mon gouvernement et qui s'appelait la
loi sur le fermage je passe depuis que
je suis revenu qu'est ce qu'on a fait
d'abord au point de vue général en a
fait l'orientation agricole
la loi d'orientation agricole et la loi
complémentaire est alors pour
transformer l'agriculture
on a appliqué une part très considérable
des revenus collectif des revenus de
l'état je vous dirais par exemple je
vous cite ces chiffres que pour soutenir
les marchés agricoles
c'est à dire pour soutenir les prix à
l'intérieur et pour aider à vendre à
l'extérieur par des subventions et ben
ont donné 500 millions par an tu parles
de nouveaux francs
quand je suis arrivé actuellement on
donne 2 milliard c'est à dire quatre
fois plus et pour ce qui est du social
de tout ce qui est social dans la
matière agricole et pour l'agriculture
ont donné quand je suis arrivé 1
milliard 400 millions
on donne aujourd'hui 7000
je parle du budget de 65 c'est à dire
cinq fois davantage
enfin il est vrai peu nous avons voulu
mon gouvernement et moi-même avons voulu
époux long pour compléter cette
transformation pour aider à cette
transformation notamment ce qui concerne
le revenu agricole que le marché commun
soit ouvert nous y reviendrons s'il vous
plaît tout à l'heure où même quand vous
voudrez mais il est vrai qu'il y a eu
des secousses dans le revenu agricole
comment en aurait-il été autrement mais
il est vrai aussi que notre cinquième
plan car il faut pas l'oublier nous
avons un plan c'est une loi est bien
notre cinquième plan prévoit que de tous
les revenus des français de revenus
toutes les catégories de français
ce sont les revenus agricoles qui dans
les cinq prochaines années doivent être
augmentées le plus voilà ce qui est fait
pour notre agriculture
par comparaison avec ce qui était fait
autrefois gênant je vous remercie tout à
l'heure en parlant les paysans vous avez
évoqué le problème de l'éducation
il faisait partie des des questions que
je vais vous poser dirais pour
l'éducation note enseignement agricole
tel qui est organisée actuellement en
1965 il ya plus professeurs pour
l'enseignement agricole qu'il n'yavait
d'élèves en 1957
voilà la réalité l'enseignement en
général qui préoccupe évidemment
beaucoup les français je dois dire que
les français sont absolument effarés par
l'abondance des réformes de
l'enseignement ils sont complètement
perdus quand on est père de famille soi
même on est complètement perdue donc il
y à cette abondance de réformes
d'enseignement qui semble traduire une
certaine incohérence je vous dis comme
les français le voient
et puis il y à tous les problèmes
pénurie de mettre pénuriques locaux etc
ce sont des problèmes extrêmement grave
et je crois que les français aimeraient
bien vous les abordez je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure que le problème de
l'enseignement était un problème
fondamental est capital de notre temps
pour la france
je veux dire par là d'abord que tous
exigent que l'enseignement soit ouvert à
tous les français et ne soient tous les
étages non seulement parce que c'est
juste mais aussi pour l'intérêt national
car dans tout ça c'est l'intérêt
national qu'il faut voir aussi et bien
l'intérêt national exige que les cadres
de la nation les petits les moyens les
cadres élevé tous les cas puisse être
puisée dans la nation tout entière dans
la jeunesse française toute entière et
que par conséquent il faut lui ouvrir
l'accès à tous les degrés de
l'enseignement c'est ce que l'on fait et
bien sûr ça exige des constructions
d'écoles énorme ça exige un recrutement
le professeur avait lui même dimension
et cela exige une scolarisation totale
de notre jeunesse
si c'était fort là qui est en cours
savez vous que quand je suis arrivé en
1958 et bien le budget de l'avant
prévoyait pour ce qui est des dépenses
concernant l'enseignement tout entier 9%
du revenu du produit ou plus exactement
du budget français est bien actuellement
il est de 17%
voilà et chiffres
ceci donne la mesure de l'effort qui a
été accompli car avant ce retour on
avait accompli rien du tout ondjiva
causait pas fait assez nicole b pour
cause est passé à vos côtés de m les
gens qui nous lisent ça ils se sont
entraînés à ce qu'ils appelaient le
pouvoir et qui n'en était pas un pendant
douze ans après mon départ en 46
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont au fait qu'est
l'école on s'y fait
quel professeur anti recruter en masse
en réalité le problème était entier il
n'avait rien fait
ils n'avaient rien prévu d'ailleurs je
suis tout naturel qu'est ce qui pouvait
prévoir
et qu'est-ce qui pouvait faire avec
leurs régies des partis mais voilà où on
en est pour l'enseignement c'est une
oeuvre qui n'est pas terminée et qui se
poursuit
je crois que le plus fort effet même en
général tout à l'heure dans ce tableau
préliminaire évoqué le problème des
routes les autoroutes à particulier le
problème du téléphone
j'aimerais que vous y reveniez quand
même brièvement parce que le téléphone
c'est devenu un lieu commun ça ne marche
pas en france à contestable mots alors
j'avais en 57 j'ai vu les chiffres et je
les ai même vu avant de causer avec vous
et bien on a fait en 1957 on a ajouté au
nombre des postes téléphoniques français
on en a ajouté 114 millions bon et bien
en 1965 on en a ajouté deux cent dix
mille voilà et j'ajoute que notre
cinquième plan comme peut-être vous le
savez est un effort très considérable
qui est prévu pour accélérer ce
développement du téléphone que tout le
monde demande aujourd'hui y compris
d'ailleurs nos campagnes et je suis du
reste le signe évident de
l'accroissement de notre prospérité et
les routes vos général les autoroutes
les routes
quand je suis arrivé il y avait soixante
dix sept kilomètres de tonte
voilà ce qu'on avait fait comme
autoroutes en france sous le régime des
partis 77 km il y en a actuellement 522
km et dans le cinquième plan il est
prévu qu'on en rajoute 18 100 kilomètres
à l'heure qu'il est il n'y a pas un pays
d'europe occidentale qui fait plus de
kilomètres d'autoroutes que nous le
faisons ok un dernier un dernier
problème également qu'il faudrait
aborder si vous voulez bien parce que ça
c'est aussi un problème d'intérêt
immédiat pour les pour les français fait
celui du logement les français est
incontestablement s'estiment mal logis
estime avoir des difficultés et à juste
titre bien souvent parfaitement raison
ce n'est pas encore une question qui
soit résolu peignant mois elle a fait
des progrès évidents et je m'en vais
vous en donner des chiffres
je vous dirais par exemple que pendant
les sept ans qui ont précédé mon retour
les 70 ans précède est mort
on a fait je me suis fait donner des
chiffres précis je les ai vérifiés
on a fait un million trois cent soixante
dix mille logements
voilà ce qu'on a fait en france pendant
sept ans avant mon retour et depuis mon
retour on a fait 2 millions 400 mille
logements pendant les sept ans quand
suivi mon retour et ça augmente car à
l'heure qu'il est on en est horrible 400
me de logements par an
et rien n'empêche de penser et j'en suis
convaincu que l'on va arriver dans un
deux trois ans à 5000 logements par an
voilà des chiffres et des réalités
c'est le joint de chair souvent ces
logements coûte cher c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs l'effort actuel comme vous le
savez l'effort de l'état est dirigée
surtout sur les logements sociaux
c'est là la part la plus considérable de
l'effort de l'état en ce qui concerne le
logement c'est parfaitement exact mon
général je crois qu'il nous reste encore
deux minutes et demie je voudrais que
vous disiez quand même quelques mots de
la recherche scientifique est un sujet
difficile enfin problèmes difficiles un
état capitale
que de choses pour ne pas dire tous qui
dépendent de la recherche scientifique
en 57 ont donné 2 % de notre budget à la
recherche scientifique public c'est à
dire ce que fait l'état pour la
recherche et bien 65 ans a donné six
pour ça et on va l'augmenter encore dans
les années qui viennent
tout ça dont nous avons parlé et bien
j'ai pas fait tout seul j'ai fait avec
un gouvernement
il est fait avec un parlement seulement
voilà ce gouvernement en était un et il
a duré et ce goût ce parlement a joué
son rôle
c'est à dire non point il ne s'est pas
perdue dans les agitations politiciennes
il s'est concentré sur sa tâche
législatives
voilà comment je le pense en septembre
nous avons largement réussi il faut
poursuivre et c'est là
le problème en général je vous remercie
et puisque vous avez accepté de revenir
demain devant les caméras de la
télévision je vous donne rendez-vous et
si vous le voulez bien nous parlerons
demain de la france par rapport au monde
je vois très volontiers c'est tentant